fresh face so fresh so face AOC enters
the swamp bernie takes the lead and
president Trump's enemies drive
themselves fully insane I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
a little behind the scenes for you every
night before I come in and do the show
in the morning I put together a
preliminary schedule and sometimes the
schedule just blows itself up in the
morning and I have to rejigger the
entire schedule so as to bring you the
latest in news that happened this
morning and there's a lot of news and
it's pretty awesome we're gonna get to
all of it in just a second first let's
talk about the blinds that you have on
your windows now I know you look around
your apartment you think oh this place
looks pretty nice but something seems
dingy you know what it is it's your
window coverings this is why you need
blinds calm let's be honest taking the
time to pick out and buy blinds sounds
expensive kind of boring installing them
yourself sound harder than any
self-respecting adult wants to a bit but
blinds calm makes it super easy for you
not sure what you want or even where to
start with blinds calm you get a free
online design consultation you just send
them pictures of your house they send
back custom recommendations from a
professional for what will work with
your color scheme your furniture and
specific rooms they will even send you
free samples to make sure everything
looks as good in person as it does
online and every order gets free
shipping and here's the best part let's
say you mess up you accidentally miss
measure or you pick the wrong color if
you make a mistake blinds Comrie make
your blinds for free which is a pretty
awesome guarantee they've really made it
easy for you there is no excuse to leave
up those mangal blinds that make it look
like you are living in some sort of
public housing hellhole for a limited
time get 20% off everything at blinds
com1 use promo code Ben that is
blinds.com promo code Ben for 20% off
everything faux wood blinds cellular
shades roller shades and more blinds.com
promo code Ben rules and restrictions to
apply blinds Comm promo code ban
alrighty so we begin today with some
unfortunate news some unfortunate news
for a OC you remember her she's the
fresh face of the Democratic Party
incredibly fresh as well as incredibly
face well it turns out according to Luke
Thompson a reporter over at medium he
has a piece up today called the
congresswoman loves the swamp sad
trombone sound guys here is what Luke
Thompson writes last Friday my mentions
died for your sins I posted a screen
grab of Riley Roberts's house microsoft
outlook card including his official
house.gov email address office phone
number and his designation as staff
roberts is the boyfriend of alexandra
Ocasio cortez the congresswoman was
upset throwing caution to the wind she
stormed into my mentions asserting this
was just a way to give mr. roberts
access to her official calendar her
chief of staff
psychotic Roberti soon followed
reiterating the calendar claim and
accusing me of daxing mr. Robert Roberts
by posting his publicly available
LinkedIn profile which he deleted and
his official government address and the
office phone number by the way putting
up a government email address and phone
number that does not qualify as daxing
neither AOC nor Chakrabarti said why
Roberts needs access to her official
calendar
regardless hordes of her howling minions
followed I was briefly suspended by
Twitter for revealing personal
information only to be released with an
apology when I pointed out that
everything I posted is government
property and therefore public my brief
stint as a digital political prisoner
turned into something of a cause celeb
on the right inviting wave upon wave of
magda enthusiasts to battle back on my
behalf against the forces of digital
socialism my timeline is still a
wasteland is what this reporter writes
during my suspension I talked to a
congressional spouse a few reporters and
some staffers from both parties AOC
hasn't exactly been winning friends
lately which is how I got Roberts's
outlook screengrab in the first place a
rumor on the hill was circulating that
Roberts had attended a congressional
progressive caucus meeting a tipster
looked to see if he'd been given staff
credentials it appeared he had all
agreed this was a regular if he was just
a spouse per the house admin office a
family member can in special
circumstances get a house gov email
address but Roberts is not a family
member and although else he referred to
him as her partner in November of last
year she omitted him from her mandatory
candidate financial disclosures for 2017
and 2018 perhaps they've gotten married
since if so if he's her spouse now we
should see his finances disclosed along
with hers in her 2019 disclosure form
due in May but to be clear
AOC did not disclose Roberts is financed
as a spouse during her campaign
regardless absent a waiver from House
Ethics family members have to be
volunteers a Oasys office apparently
doesn't believe in having unpaid workers
as according to chakrabarti they have no
volunteers in the office so Roberts is
designated his staff but also isn't on
AOC staff even though he showed up
Friday morning in the house directory as
processing into her personal office as a
staffer in other words his staff status
status like his spouse status is akin to
Schrodinger's cat this ought to have
been enough to make it clear that AOC
story didn't add up more importantly I'd
clearly hit a nerve so Luke Thompson
writes over at medium Chakrabarti who is
again a o C's chief of staff spend much
of his day in my mentions insisting that
everything was on the up-and-up with
Roberts instead of asking if Roberts had
been supplied with the badge and pin
appropriate to a congressional spouse
evidence of which her office should have
been
produce easily a o'seas worshipful
stenographers in the press went into
overdrive witless li repeating her
talking points Jeff Stein over at the
Washington Post even woke up Saturday to
keep it going in my mentions as his
Chakrabarti himself and of course AOC
had decided to get into it that's a lot
of time and effort spent refuting a GOP
consultant known to a tiny corner of the
internet for posting cat pictures and
bitching about the doctrine of co-equal
branches so I went to the FCC did a
little searching and discovered that lo
and behold there is more to the story
now during the original kerfuffle some
folks noticed that a Oasys campaign had
paid Roberts $1,750 that is not quite
what transpired Roberts was paid only as
a means of keeping accounting in order
in the first half of 2018 Roberts did
some free work for the campaign that
work got put on the books as an in-kind
contribution and then discharged as an
expenditure for accounting purpose that
is perfectly normal it's a way to keep
people from circumventing federal
contribution caps by providing
discounted or free services but that is
not the only political work Roberts
ostensibly did during the cycle nor
would it be the first time Chakrabarti
had hired Roberts he's done - at least
once before in 2017 although it's
unlikely Roberts was hired to do any
actual work in that case so here is
weird things get a little dicey for aoc
at the beginning of 2017 Chakrabarty
created brand new Congress an
organization dedicated to shaking things
up in Democratic primaries it's a rather
ingenious organization but one that
dwells in a legal gray area as far as
campaign finance law is concerned it
facilitates campaigns on shoestring
budgets by providing a single Clearing
House for campaign services generally
filed under the banner of strategic
consulting but as a result it limits the
meaningfulness of FEC closures
disclosures by these campaigns
additionally it means that brand new
Congress
unlike most PACs spends most of its
budget on overhead and makes relatively
few actual contributions to candidates
additionally brand new Congress is not
one thing but rather two it's a non
qualified political action committee a
PAC that can raise in bundle campaign
contributions for candidates donations
and expenditures from PACs like those -
and by candidates are publicly disclosed
however brand new Congress is also an
LLC owned by Chakrabarti remember
Chakrabarti AOC chief of staff that
provides campaign services to candidates
to help lower the barriers to entry
LLC's do not have to disclose her
itemized their spending this is a clever
way to try to make running for office
easier and to place a lot of small bets
on a lot of insurgent candidates and
hope for a few lucky wins and that
pretty much seems to
what happened according to FEC records
the pack was founded in mid-january of
2017 at the end of February it
affiliated with justice Democrats a
collaboration between Chakrabarti and
chanc Eiger of The Young Turks the two
organizations are inextricably linked
Chakrabarti lists himself as a
co-founder of both brand new Congress
and justice Democrats on his LinkedIn
page over the course of the cycle
justice Democrats hoop a brand new
Congress LLC six hundred five thousand
eight hundred forty nine dollars they
would also share an address in may brand
new Congress changed the address for its
custodian of Records to Tennessee in
August and switched addresses again but
in December of 2017 Justice Democrats
registered at the same address
AOC also used that Tennessee address in
her first candidate filing which
incorrectly registered her to run in New
York's 15th congressional district five
days later she switched to the
fourteenth and two months after that the
campaign committees address was changed
to the Bronx as well a quick tour
through a o'seas campaign expenditures
reveals the extent to which brand new
Congress midwife's her campaign into
existence precisely as the frequently
asked questions described would have had
it but a o'seas campaign was different
from others backed by brand new Congress
PAC and not simply because she won like
other candidates AOC paid brand new
Congress LLC for strategic consulting in
her case totaling eighteen thousand
eight hundred eighty dollars unlike in
the other cases brand new Congress PAC
turned around and paid her boyfriend as
a marketing consultant indeed while
brand new Congress packs ten largest
expenditures were paid to brand new
Congress LLC for strategic consulting a
summit total 261 thousand dollars over
the course of her campaign its eleventh
and twelfth largest expenditures were
paid to Riley Roberts brand new Congress
PAC paid Roberts three thousand bucks on
August 9th eighteen days later a OCS
campaign paid brand new Congress six
thousand one hundred ninety one dollars
a month later brand new Congress then
turned around and paid Riley another
three thousand dollars so why would
Chakrabarti a founding engineer at
stripe and wealthy veteran of Silicon
Valley be hiring a no-name UX
experienced guy with little discernible
marketing experience to serve as brand
new Congress PACs sole marketing
consultant the answer seems to be that
Chakrabarty was funneling money paid to
him by a o'seas campaign back to roberts
and by extension to AOC in other words a
o'seas campaign she raised a bunch of
money she paid her chief of staff who
had a consulting firm and he in turn
paid the money directly to her boyfriend
this is the allegation by Luke Thompson
which is pretty swampy
at the beginning of October more than
four months into her campaign a o'seas
fundraising had been anemic excluding an
in-kind contribution for Chakrabarti she
raised only three thousand bucks but had
already spent twenty seven thousand
dollars more than half of which she had
paid to chakrabarti is brand new
Congress LLC by the end of 2017 she'd
spent 37 thousand dollars but raised
only eight thousand dollars that's a lot
of money to stick on a credit card since
no loans are recorded on her campaign
books presumably either AOC or Roberts
was fronting the necessary cash it looks
to me like Chakrabarti was effectively
reimbursing AOC for a third of her
expenses with brand new Congress LLC
perhaps so that she would stay in the
race despite her mounting debt the
shadiness of the whole business may also
explain why roberts who's a o C's
boyfriend lists his residence as Arizona
for the expenditure rather than New York
Roberts is from Arizona but was living
in New York with AOC his other
contributions to her campaign both cash
and in-kind list New York as his
residence regardless of whether or not
Roberts was officially AOC spouse at
that time it seems probable chakrabarti
was reimbursing her for her campaign
expenses off books brand new Congress
PAC simply served as a pass-through to
do so when AOC one she then hired
Chakrabarti as her chief of staff taking
money from a rich guy trying to hide it
by passing it through a PAC and then
giving her benefactor a government job
that is definitely unethical and
potentially illegal so in other words
she was raising money but I wasn't clear
that she was actually raising enough
money to pay her boyfriend so she just
went to Chakrabarti and somebody to
float my boyfriend the money is the
suggestion here that's the allegation
and then she went and hired the guy who
gave her boyfriend a loan on
congressional staff dollars Chakrabarti
may have made an illegal campaign
contribution in excess of federal limits
regardless it raises questions about
chakra parties hiring as a Oasys chief
of staff after her election but all of
the above is based on public information
says the reporter had sent me a couple
of hours to pull it all together and
write it up reporters are just lazy so
that is not a great story for AOC who is
remount and remember she is the fresh
new face so fresh so face of the
Democratic Party very much against the
swamp against corruption and now it
turns out that she may in fact have been
violating campaign law at the very least
she was working with a firm that was
apparently funneling money back to her
via her boyfriend which is really
corrupt and it turns out that then she
hires the head of that firm as her chief
of staff now I'm
remember one's a nationalist Susan went
to jail for illegal campaign
contributions I'm old enough to remember
that so don't give me the everybody
breaks the rules if you're on the Left I
don't believe in campaign finance rules
by the way they figure up to me I don't
really care what happens with all this
stuff Chakrabarti wants to give a Oasys
boyfriend some money and then he wants
to join her office whatever I don't
really care because money in politics is
endemic to politics that's just the way
things work doesn't bother me all that
much I will say however that the massive
hypocrisy of members of Congress doing
this kind of stuff and then claiming
that they are standing for truth justice
and the Soviet Way is pretty astonishing
and Congress indeed is getting crazier
pretty much all the time
I mean aoc you'll recall is radical of
high order and so are a lot of her
fellow members of Congress as whether
talking tax rates of 90 percent
eliminating private health care
abortions to the point of birth a green
new deal that would cost fifty trillion
dollars this is all insane Congress
isn't changing anytime soon and neither
is either party but we can stop the
abuse of federal power right now we can
call a convention of states the states
can get together to propose amendments
to the Constitution to impose term
limits a balanced budget and put limits
on the power of the federal government
Congress has no power to stop us
thirteen states have already passed it
we are working on the remaining states
right now to fix the broken system in
Washington you should add your voice to
the call for a convention of states of
which I'm a fans who join me and my
friend mark McClure and sign the
petition at convention of states calm
slash pen to get involved go to
convention of states calm slash ban that
is indeed convention of states calm
slash man a lot of folks will say well
at a convention of states will you have
a runaway convention no you won't have a
runaway convention because the
convention of states is going to be
called largely by conservative states
and conservative delegates are going to
be the ones writing up the proposed
constitutional amendments that would
help shore up a lot of the holes that
have been poked into the Constitution by
the left over the last century and a
half go check it out a convention of
states calm slash been and join and add
your voice to the call for a convention
of states that is convention of states
calm slash ban convention of states calm
at slash ban well all of this is is bad
news for AOC obviously because she poses
herself as above the fray purrr than the
driven snow an ideologue of ideologues
and i mean she's doing so like today
like she's calling out CN n for
corruption the same day that it turns
out that she may have actually been
funneling money via her chief
to her boyfriend it turns out that she
is calling out CNN why is she calling
out CNN because the left is very angry
at CNN today I know I know it's it's
like the iran-iraq war who do you root
for exactly but the left is very upset
with CNN why well they're upset because
they hired Sarah Oscar Flores he's a
former spokeswoman for Jeff Sessions
they hired her as one of their political
editors to help oversee coverage of the
2020 presidential campaign and this
prompted AOC so fresh so face to say in
a tweet sorry didn't get the latest memo
after a thousand experienced and
qualified journalists of all stripes
were let go without warning a few weeks
ago and still looking for work are we
still pretending that hires like these
are evidence of a meritocracy
I remember when AAAS he was just this
upset about George Stephanopoulos being
the chief political correspondent for
NBC or ABC rather after being Hillary
Clinton's chief of staff I recall her
being super upset when the brother of
Ben Rhodes who was the national security
adviser under Barack Obama was the head
of CBS News
I remember being super upset about Chris
Cuomo who was Andrew Cuomo's brother
being a news anchor on CNN I mean I
remember her being upset about all these
things it's very upsetting it's very
upsetting
the amount of hatred for anyone who has
served in the Trump administration going
back into the press is pretty
astonishing I'm gonna get to more of
that in just one second there's a story
from The Daily Beast pointing out how
terrible this is by the way full
disclosure I know Sarah at scarf Laura
she and I went to Harvard Law School at
the same time very nice gal highly
qualified extremely intelligent and
being a political editor at CNN just
means you sort of help choose which
stories to cover CNN having one person
who voted for Trump on staff is not the
end of the world guys it's totally okay
it's totally okay I love the people in
the press who have been passing back and
forth out of Democratic administrations
as long as I have been alive remember
Jay Carney the Obama spokesperson used
to work for Time magazine they've been
passing in and out of this for a very
long time now of a sudden it's shocked
shocked that somebody who worked for
Jeff Sessions who by the way President
Trump was not particularly fond of is
now going to be working over at CNN
according to The Daily Beast CNN
staffers are upset and confused about
the network's decision to hire a
partisan political operative to oversee
its 2020 campaign reporting again this
has never happened before partisan
political operatives and major news
networks say
so that might be impossible on Tuesday a
CNN spokesperson confirmed to Daily
Beast that the network had hired
Republican political adviser Sarah Iskar
as the politics editor helming CNN's
20/20 coverage the move was first
reported by Politico scre serves as an
advisor to Ted Cruz and Mitt Romney she
was Carly fiorina's deputy campaign
manager for the 2016 Republican primary
and then she worked for Jeff Sessions a
CNN spokesperson said Iskra will not be
involved in the network's DOJ coverage
but will guide TV and digital coverage
of the 20/20 election occasionally
offering on-screen analysis as well one
network editorial staffer said it's
extremely demoralizing for everyone here
because if there's a Republican in here
man how are we going to talk to people
people are generally confused to another
editorial employee adding the decision
to hire a partisan operative for an
editorial position comes off as very
bizarre CNN's reliable sources anchor
brian Stelter reported on the network's
perspective tweeting loved it or hated
political insiders have been joining
newsrooms for decades the more
viewpoints represented in newsrooms the
better as for the critiques CNN PRS
declined to comment and that is that is
100% true it is a hundred percent true
there are so many members of political
campaigns in newsrooms that the false
objective journalism ik nonsense that
you hear from these newsrooms it has
been alive for a very very long time
nonetheless people are very upset on the
left because esker should never be
allowed in the newsroom just terrible
just here just awful CNN's Jeff Zucker
has said before he wanted to bring a
little more balance to the newsroom so
it really shouldn't be that big a shot
but anytime any Republican is hired by
any major outlet it becomes an issue for
that outlet not not a particular
surprise not a particularly surprise at
all okay meanwhile Trump derangement
syndrome has gone completely off the
rails completely off the rails
the latest indicator is not just the
jussie Smollett case but President Trump
put out a policy yesterday he was going
to launch a global campaign to
decriminalize homosexuality in dozens of
Nations where anti-gay laws are still on
the books now this seems like a policy
that pretty much everybody can get
behind right left center no one really
believes that it should be criminal
activity for gay people to have
with each other right that is not a
thing that anyone really believes in
Western civilization anymore whether you
believe that this activity is a sin or
not the idea of a government busting
into somebody's bedroom and prosecuting
them for their private activity is
something that no person who believes in
a free society should really be in favor
of consenting adults participating in
activity of what you do not approve does
not give you the license as a government
to go in and stop them from from doing
what they want to do and president Trump
who by the way has been very LGBTQ
friendly particularly LGB friendly has
been very gay friendly that this is not
a surprise coming from him his
ambassador to Germany is rich Grinnell
who is a gay an openly gay man President
Trump held up a gay pride flag in the
middle of his campaign in 2016 how weird
is Trump derangement syndrome Trump
derangement syndrome is so strong that
gay magazines are now angry at President
Trump for attempting to decriminalize
homosexuality in a variety of nations
around the world out magazine has an
article today here is what it is called
Trump's plan to decriminalize
homosexuality is an old racist tactic
what now so Iran hangs gay people Trump
says don't do that and that's cuz he's a
racist when you are so woke when your
brain is so woke that you are actually
brain dead that's where we are right now
so I I do not understand this
legitimately it's it's impossible to
understand this sort of logic because
it's completely illogical so Iran hangs
gay people and you're like Matt's
multiculturalism he's cracking down on
multiculturalism by telling them to stop
hanging gay people from cranes so a
magazine is a piece by Matthew Rodriguez
it says well on its surface the move
looks like an a typically benevolent
decision by the Trump administration the
details of the campaign Balai a
different story rather than actually
being about helping queer people around
the world the campaign looks like more
like an instance of the right using
queer people as pawns to amass power and
enact its own agenda they say the most
telling detail of NBC's News's report is
that his plan centers homophobic
violence in Iran who NBC News calls the
administration's top geopolitical foe so
really what they are saying is that
it's very bad that Trump is anti-iran on
the basis of them hanging gay people
from cranes because we don't want to go
to war with Iran because we like Iran
even though they hang gay people from
cranes which is weird and it's not just
this out magazine article Human Rights
Campaign put out a tweet storm saying
the Trump pence administration has
consistently worked to undermine the
fundamental equality of LGBTQ people and
our families from day one and they have
a long thread about how terrible it is
that they made this decision
they say if this commitment is real we
have a lot of questions about their
intentions and commitments and are eager
to see what proof and action will follow
so if your first reaction to the Trump
administration doing something
incredibly benevolent on behalf of gay
people the world over is we are deeply
suspicious that this is another racist
move by the Trump derangement syndrome
and that is some strong strong stuff
these people are smoking I mean that is
it's deadly Trump derangement syndrome
has now reached a deadly proportions
it's fully crazy in a second I'll give
you the latest on the jussie Smollett
case which demonstrates that Trump
arrangment syndrome can actually lead
you directly to prison
I'll get to that in just a second but
first let us talk about how you defend
your rights when the founders crafted
the Constitution the first thing they
did was to make sacred the rights of the
individual to share their ideas without
limitation by their governments the
second right they enumerated was the
right of the population to protect that
speech and their own persons with force
you know how strongly I believe in these
principles I'm a gun owner owning a
rifle is an awesome responsibility
building rifles is no different Bravo
company manufacturing was started in a
garage by a marine vet more than two
decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they're a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer and
manufacture life-saving equipment they
assume every rifle leaving their shop
will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or a soldier
overseas each components of a BCM rifle
is hand assembled and tested by
Americans to a life-saving standard BCM
feels a moral responsibility as
Americans to provide tools that will not
fail the user when it's not just a paper
target but someone coming to do them
actual harm to learn more about Bravo
company manufacturing head on over to
Bravo Company MFG comm where you can
discover more about their products
special offers upcoming news that is
Bravo Company MFG comm if you need more
convincing
go check
them out at youtube.com slash Bravo
company USA can meet the awesome people
who make their products Bravo Company
MFG comm go check them out right now and
get yourself a nice weapon I mean you
need to defend yourself Bravo Company
MFG dot-com so here's the latest on the
jussie Smollett case the latest on the
jussie Smollett case is that the two
brothers involved in the Jesse Smollett
attack told police that small it was not
just behind the fake attack he was also
behind creating a fake racist letter
that was sent to the actor on the set of
his show Empire according to two sources
with first-hand knowledge of the
investigation when the letter did not
get a bigger reaction Smollett than
orchestrated the attack a week later
with the two men ola and Abel a Sendero
sources said
also on Tuesday sources said the two
brothers were seen on a rideshare video
camera before being dropped off there
the location of the attack
Smollett received a letter containing a
white powder On January 22nd the letter
was mailed to Chicago's Sena spaced
Studios where the show Empire is filmed
the letter prompted a hazmat response
CPD said the white substance was later
determined to be aspirin the note was
crafted with letters apparently cut out
from magazines to form words the penis
the piece together message contains
racial and homophobic threats directed
at Smollett a magazine is one of the
pieces of evidence retrieved from the
brothers home last week during a search
conducted by CPD investigators also
recovered a book of stamps genius says
so I mean it's gonna be kind of
hilarious when it turns out that not
only did they cut the letters from the
magazine they then kept the magazine how
good is that magazine and you're
committing a federal crime by sending in
a threat through the mails and you keep
the magazine you cut the letters out
from Ike all you had to do is toss it
the recycling guys really so Jesse
Smollett is obviously a troubled human
being he's obviously a seriously
troubled human being who will end up in
federal prison I mean this is now a
federal crime once you start sending
things through the mails and you have a
real problem but the reason that people
believed him is because they believed in
a narrative about President Trump the
same way that out Magazine believes a
narrative about President Trump that
he's a brutal terrible homophobe and
therefore everything that people say
that is bad about Trump is true and
everything good they say must inevitably
be false Geraldo Rivera basically
admitted this yesterday's and we
believed Smollett because racism is real
like this was so incendiary accord on
because it was
you know kind of justifying and
reaffirming the stereotype that people
had I mean it was so paitent ly obvious
and yet because it is so toxic racism
and because we want justice in this
country when people have a fair shake
we bought this guy's unbelievable tale
why do we believe these stories racism
is real look at that what happened in
Charleston that's a real story okay and
it is true that people jump to these
conclusions because they are eager to
continue showing that America is a
deeply racist terrible place and these
hoaxes started long before President
Trump this isn't trumped arrangment
syndrome this is America derangement
syndrome for a lot of folks this is
people think that America is a terrible
awful no good very bad place steeped in
racism bigotry sexism homophobia and
therefore in the attempt to continue
painting America this way every story
that can be used as a data point in
defense of that narrative will be pushed
out there will be promoted will be
trumpeted will be made more audible that
that is the goal of many members of the
media and it's a really sad goal it's a
really sad goal and what you see over
and over when it comes to this sort of
America's arrangment syndrome is that
any piece of data in favor of a silly
narrative that is not true that America
is an awful awful place gets pushed to
the absolute limit gets pushed to the
absolute limit Americans arrangment
syndrome is merely the broader version
of Trump derangement syndrome Trump is
not America and America is not Trump but
the anger at Trump existed for Bush it
exists for all conservatives this is why
when people say the Trump is being
disproportionately hit people hate Trump
more than they've ever hated anyone else
that's true but they also hated
President Bush and if Ted Cruz were
president there would be a Cruz
derangement syndrome the bottom line is
that President Trump believes that
America is not a terrible place and this
in and of itself is enough of a sin to
earn him a drayman syndrome then on top
of that President Trump happens to be a
very toxic polarizing figure he's a guy
who says a lot of things that piss
people off but with all of that said
Trump derangement syndrome for the left
is really a subset of a broader
derangement syndrome and this is why the
left is trying to oust president Trump
it really has almost nothing to do with
Trump I mean this is the great lie about
President Trump it's kind of fun it
really is fascinating the great lie
about President Trump
is that President Trump is seen as as an
outlier from American politics that is
simply not true if you go back to 2016
and you look at the percentages that he
won the percentages that he won
state-by-state were very similar to the
percentages that Mitt Romney won the
left paints every Republican with the
same brush which is one of the reasons
Trump was nominated in the first place
because Republicans had fine you're
gonna paint us with this brush we'll
just do this thing you want a piece of
this fine come on here's a giant
pulsating middle finger to you his name
is Donald Trump but again Trump
derangement syndrome is just the latest
iteration of an anti American anti
conservative derangement syndrome when I
say anti American I don't mean that
folks can't be Patriots or that they are
hating America what I am saying is that
they paint a vision of America that's a
lot darker in terms of his history and
current presence then is warranted by
the evidence meanwhile speaking of Trent
derangement syndrome the media continue
to push the narrative the president
Trump is in the pay of Russia again
without any evidence
yesterday Andrew McCabe the former fired
interim FBI director he came out he said
on CNN
well maybe president Trump is being paid
by Russia maybe he's a Russian asset
again Andrew McCabe worked for the FBI
the FBI I was led to believe over the
course of my career in life actually
required evidence before making
allegations like this but Andy McKay
posing as the quintessential Fed says
Naruto maybe Trump really is in the pay
of the Russians do you still believe the
president could be a Russian asset I
think it's possible I think that's why
we started our investigation and I'm
really anxious to see where director
Muller concludes that okay so he's got
no evidence he says it's possible and
we're supposed to just go along with
that then and CNN national security
analyst gets on TV and says Vladimir
Putin could be controlling the White
House the Samantha vina grad who served
on the National Security Council under
Barack Obama mccabe has said that the
president's moves to undercut Russia
related investigations to believe blood
amir putin over his intelligence
community to make personnel decisions
based upon russian related matters all
led to this investigation mckay would
have laid that out before the gang of
eight this on investigation is
continuing and there is still a chance
that vladimir putin is controlling the
White House yeah I mean these are
astonishing allegations that are being
made without any real evidence that the
allegations are true but again Trump
derangement syndrome
continues to be promoted across
mainstream media not a second we're
gonna jump into the 2020 race we will
give you all the updates Bernie Sanders
has really shaken up the race and must
be considered until Joe Biden jumps in
the front-runner in this race will
explain why in just a second first let's
talk about your sleep quality there's
nobody on the planet like you so why in
the world would you buy a generic
mattress that is built for random human
hulex sleep has built a sleep quiz it
takes two minutes to complete they use
the answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper
or a hot sleeper whether you like a
plush or from bed with helix there's no
more guessing in no more confusion just
go to helix sleep calm slash men take
their two-minute sleep quiz they will
match you to a mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life four
couples helix can even split the
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they have a 10
year warranty you get to try it out for
a hundred nights for its grace you
really have nothing to lose I can tell
you helix sleep mattresses incredibly
comfortable my wife and I have one it
was tailored just for us it really is
phenomenal
right now helix is offering up to $200
off mattress orders for their Presidents
Day sale so thank you George Washington
get up to 200 bucks off at helix sleep
comm slash Ben that is helix sleep calm
slash Ben for $200 off your mattress
order for their Presidents Day sale
going on right now
helix sleep calm slash Ben go check them
out right now helix sleep calm slash
bended up to 200 bucks off at helix
sleep calm slash Ben alrighty so time
for your 2020 update Bernie Sanders
jumped into the race yesterday and he
really shook things up on his very first
day in the race Bernie Sanders raised I
kid you not four million dollars within
48 hours he had raised more than six
million dollars I mean it is astonishing
stuff we'll get to that in just a second
first you're gonna have to go over to
daily wire and subscribe for $9.99 a
month you can get a subscription to
daily wire not only that not only that
for $99 a year you can get the annual
subscription which comes along with all
sorts of goodies including two more
hours per day of my show also my new
book the right side of history details
the crisis of purpose that is happening
right now in Western civilization again
the title the book is the right side of
history if you want to know how he got
here and how he can get back on track
pre-order today at Amazon Barnes & Noble
in any major bookseller I really can't
wait to share it with you that is coming
out March 19th pre-order it now so it
doesn't run out of stock it's already
selling really really well go check it
out
right now when you get the subscription
$4.99
a year you get all sorts of goodies gets
me behind the paywall with me ask me
questions during the breaks in the show
you get also this the very greatest and
beverage vessels left two steers hot or
cold tumbler and right now if you take a
picture with your leftist here's hot or
cold tumblr and you hashtag it leftist
here's tumblr you put it on Instagram or
you put it on Twitter then you may show
up your face may show up in all of its
glory on the bench Shapiro show so go
check that out also make sure you
subscribe over at YouTube or iTunes
because then you get the Sunday special
now when you're a subscriber to daily
wire you get the Sunday special on
Saturday which means that you get it a
day early for those of us keeping track
at home it's a go check that our and our
latest Sunday special is with the
awesome Larry elder the first guy I ever
did a radio interview with actually when
I was 17 years old Larry and I did a
Sunday special it really is a lot of fun
hi I'm Larry elder and I'm participating
in ben shapiro sunday special we talk
about barack obama we talk about donald
trump we talk about race and racism we
talk about libertarianism we talk about
where the country is going so check it
out it really is going to be riveting if
I do say so myself so much good stuff go
check it out YouTube iTunes leave us a
review we always appreciate it we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
radio show and podcast in the nation
[Music]
all right so back to the 2020 race
Bernie Sanders has picked up an enormous
amount of money apparently according to
Nick Visser over at Huffington Post
Bernie raised six million dollars in the
first 24 hours after announcing his 2020
presidential bid apparently there are a
lot of people who are willing to give
their money to a guy who wants to steal
everybody else's money more than 225,000
people have already donated to Bernie
Sanders his campaign that number is way
ahead of everybody else it is more than
double the 1.5 million dollars raised by
Camilla Harris in her first 24 hours he
is raising an average of 27 bucks a
person so it means a lot of small donors
the Democratic field is already crowded
but by polling data Bernie is doing
incredibly well in the polls right now
there is a tracking poll that Real Clear
Politics has been highlighting showing
exactly where everybody shows up here
and right now it looks like Biden at 28%
is there the Real Clear Politics poll
averages Biden at 28% Sanders at 17%
Kamala Harris at 10% Warren at 7 Roark
at 6 and Booker at 5 and then everybody
else is basically a corpse at this point
Gillibrand by the way does not even show
up in these polls
nobody likes Kirsten Gillibrand as
really a little straight for you in just
a second so Joe Biden is the other shoe
to drop everybody is still waiting for
Joe Biden to jump in the race but for
the moment Bernie is the front runner
which is pretty astonishing because the
guy is not only an open quote-unquote
democratic socialist back in the day he
was like an actual commie and now he's
hiding the communism by saying that he
likes Norway and he likes Sweden in all
of us but back in the 1980s he really
didn't hide it Bernie Sanders back in
the flashback praising Fidel Castro and
talking about how the word socialism
doesn't frighten him socialist the word
socialism does not frighten me and I
think it's probably fair to say that the
Nicaraguan government is primarily a
socialist government you may recall way
back in moments of 1961 they invaded
Cuba and everybody was totally convinced
the Castro was the worst guy in the
world all the Cuban people were going to
rise up and
against Fidel Castro they'd forgot that
he educated the kids gave them the
health care totally transformed a
society but just because Ronald Reagan
dislikes these people does not mean to
say that the people in their own nations
feel the same way which is why they have
a dictatorship when they haven't had a
free election in 60 years so Bernie
Sanders back in 1985 defending the
Castros who are legitimately throwing
dissidents in prison for dozens of years
people in Cuba getting on legitimately
old 1950s Cadillacs with the tires
inflated trying to float their way to
Miami and Bernie Sanders is sitting
there going it was great
it's quick and that guy is now the
frontrunner for the Democratic Party
slow clap for the Democrats guys I mean
really really well done stuff Bernie
Sanders though even Bernie has to lie
about his own agenda this is the dirty
little secret is that Bernie despite all
of his vast on the street about American
politics he will not actually tell you
the impact of his own program so Bernie
Sanders was talking about health care
yesterday and Lluis talk about his
Medicare for all plan and he dropped a
line that is so eminently false that
even fact checkers on the Left were
blowing up Bernie that's not true he was
talking about Medicare for all and he
suggested that if you like your doctor
you're going to be able to keep your
doctor and it will be cheaper under
Medicare for all you're offering
something that the polling shows people
can get very spook very quickly no well
but that's because we're going to be
taking on the insurance companies and
the drug companies we're going to spend
a whole lot of money distorting what we
believe in for example they're gonna say
people you're gonna lose your current
health insurance and employment yeah but
you're gonna have the same exact doctor
you're gonna have more freedom of choice
on our proposal than you have under the
current proposals the average
middle-class family will save money will
spend less money on health care will
have more choice and have broader
coverage than it's currently the case
ball bleep yeah I mean really bull bleep
you know the only thing you could
possibly say is that if you nationalize
the health system the way the Bernie
Sanders wants to then on a per capita
taxing level we might spend less than we
do on a violent eristic level like
people forget a lot of what we spend on
our health care system is us coming out
of our own pocket because we want fast
coverage America has a couple of massive
advantages over other health care system
one you want a surgery tomorrow you can
get a surgery tomorrow you don't have to
wait in line you don't have to wait for
the government to ration it to you
you're not going to have to wait
for cancer screenings you're not gonna
have to wait for any of that stuff the
fact is the United States still has the
world's best five-year survival rate for
virtually all cancers the United States
is still the repository of nearly all
medical innovation on planet Earth on
planet Earth more than half of all new
drugs are produced in the United States
and would be higher if the FDA weren't
so insane in its regulatory overreach it
is true that the United States is more
expensive than other nations but if you
remove the amount of money that we spend
on healthcare on per capita level from
our GDP on a per capita level we are
still number one or number two in the
world in other words we spend a lot of
money on healthcare because many of us
want to spend a lot of money on health
care
also because we heavily subsidize really
heavily subsidize our medical system 49
percent of all medical spending in the
United States is done by the federal
government is done by the government
through Medicaid and through Medicare
the idea that there isn't government
health care provided in the United
States is simply nonsense when he says
if you like your doctor gonna listen
even Obamacare wouldn't let you keep
your doctor once they decided to rewrite
all the regulations this is why when
Bernie Sanders has a choice if he wants
his nationalized health care system he
must abolish private insurance if he
does not abolish private insurance then
people are simply going to purchase
supplemental insurance and most doctors
are going to start taking that insurance
and not taking the government insurance
because reimbursement rates when private
insurance are higher than reimbursements
from Medicare and Medicaid this is why
many doctors now will not take Medicare
or Medicaid patients the only way to
guarantee the doctors will do that is to
prohibit them from taking money from
private insurers by abolishing private
insurers I mean there are other ways to
do this but that's not the way the
Bernie Sanders wants to do it Oh Avenue
who is supposed to be on our show a
little bit later today talking about
health care systems he recommends the
Swiss model the Swiss model has an
individual mandate where every person
pays into a private health insurance
system and then you have choice among
your health insurers you have choice
among your doctors that's not what
Bernie is talking about that's not what
Bernie is talking about Bernie is going
way beyond Obamacare
okay so he Boches that but you know no
matter no matter what makes Bernie
popular is the fact that he is a truth
teller that he is it written note I will
say there's one area in which Bernie
Sanders is a lot better than the other
Democrats and it's one of the reasons
why Bernie Sanders may in fact have a
plurality run to the nomination it's
kind of fascinating so Bernie
in his opening interview he talked about
intersectionality Bernie's been trying
to play both sides of this coin he's
been trying to say America's racist
sexist bigoted I'm homophobic but he
then will say we ought to have a
meritocracy
now the left agrees with the first part
but the hard left disagrees with the
second part they don't believe a
meritocracy is even possible they don't
believe that we should judge people by
their abilities they believe we should
judge people by their group identity
because in the view of the radical left
all human relationships can be
attributed to power hierarchies and
imbalances of power so there's no such
thing as a meritocracy there are just
imbalances of power but Bernie Sanders
doesn't actually believe that deep down
Bernie Sanders is while he's a communist
well he's an actual Marxist Bernie
Sanders he still has this gut level
belief because he grew up in the United
States in a meritocracy and so he says
some stuff that makes him kind of
unpopular on the intersectional Left
there's a problem for him in one area
and kind of a win for him in another
here's Bernie Sanders saying something
that violates the tenets of
intersectionality we have got to look at
candidates not by the color of their
skin not by their sexual orientation of
the agenda and not by their age I mean I
think we have got to try to move us
toward a non-discriminatory society
which looks at people based on their
abilities based on what they stand for
this is a big boo-boo you're not allowed
to say this inside the Democratic Party
this is why from my money for my money
Bernie Sanders is less dangerous to
America than Camela Harris's because I
believe that Bernie Sanders is idiotic
domestic agenda is not going to happen
the American people aren't going to
stand for it
Congress is not going to pass it if they
do pass it they will immediately revoke
it there will instead be a wave election
for Roberta Sanders were to be elected
president god forbid in 2020 in 2022
there would be a wave congressional
election for Republicans not only
because we do this every four years but
also because nobody actually wants
Bernie's policy proposals but Bernie is
a lot more like Trump when it comes to
the idea that he is in favor of a
non-racial meritocracy this is not what
the Democratic Party wants and so
Stephen Colbert who is a full-time
pander bear he comes out and he says
it's just terrible that Bernie Sanders
would say something like this it's
pretty amazing actually
the field was almost
way more diverse this time with multiple
women people of color the first openly
gay major Party presidential candidate
but Sanders for all that diversity
Bernie Sanders did not believe that
hurts his chances like dr. King I have a
dream a dream where this diverse nation
can come together and be led by an old
white guy where do I find the courage
also where do I find the pudding I want
pudding
well he's ripping off my pudding joke
now Stephen Colbert huh now that hurts a
little bit I mean at least at least
attribute the joke if you're not gonna
have me on your stupid show
in any case Stephen close the pudding
thing is mine you catch grab the put
anything come on in any case is Colbert
going after Bernie Sanders for not being
intersectional enough and this is gonna
be the battle inside the Democratic
Party and if I have to root for one side
of the Kamala Harris intersectional
politics versus Bernie Sanders non
intersectional socialism I'll go with
Bernie honestly because I think the
greatest damage beings under the country
right now is not even the battle between
bigger government and smaller government
it's the battle between tribalism and
non tribalism if bernie is arguing in
favor of non tribalism even by accident
that's a lot better to me then the
intersectional politics being pushed by
the hardcore left it's also why Bernie
Sanders is going to do
disproportionately well among non
college educated white people in
primaries and maybe in the general
election Pamela Harris is hoping that
she can crowd Bernie out when it comes
to the the black lane the the
african-american lane of the Democratic
Party and maybe that's right but Bernie
could strike back by doing incredibly
well among white folks in such primaries
now the question is whether those white
folks are so woke that they have
embraced the same intersectional
politics that common law Harris is
counting on right if they look more like
Stephen Colbert if they're angry at
Bernie for violating the tenets of
intersectionality it really is kind of a
fascinating thing when Bernie Sanders is
more Pro America in his vision of race
then Kamala Harris really really a
fascinating fascinating thing
considering that Bernie's like an actual
Soviet and meanwhile there are a couple
of updates on other candidates of
kirsten gillibrand who takes every
position Under the Sun continues to
flail about nonsensically nobody knows
why kirsten gillibrand is even in the
race including Kirsten Gillibrand
Kirsten Gillibrand
had a very awkward moment she was in
Iowa and she was speaking and people
just decided that they weren't
interested in hearing her one lady is
trying get through and kirsten
gillibrand like what do you have a
question and lady nope just want some
ranch dressing lady and that is all of
America that lady for president I'm just
trying it to the ranch dressing senator
I have no interest in this at all
Kirsten Gillibrand is the most forced
candidate which makes her high larious
she is so funny so she did a cooking
thing last night because this is and
this is now a thing everybody who runs
for president has to cook honestly like
if I were to run for president my video
would be me just going to a restaurant
and ordering something because number
one I do it more often than cooking and
so do all the rest of these candidates
gave you think Kirsten Gillibrand is at
home cooking every night or AOC is at
home with her instant pot every night as
opposed to just ordering out you're
insane okay it's not true but Kirsten
Gillibrand tweets this out she's so
forced she is she's so mechanical she
tweets out quote some might say that
running unabashedly as a mom is risky
not to me parents have skin in the game
for the country we leave to our kids
that's why I'm fighting for paid leave
health care and climate action I'll
fight for every kid like they're my own
well first of all my kid is certainly
not your kid lady you don't even know my
kids names I don't want you anywhere
near my kids but secondly I love the the
straw man that running an unabashedly as
a mom is risky it's true super risky
people hate mothers hate them if there's
one group in America that is
discriminated against its moms we
fricking hate those people
moms got to make sure Wow look at she's
so risk seeking what a hero not all
heroes wear capes but apparently all
heroes wear aprons because everybody has
to wear one in the kitchen now so that's
exciting
by the way Kamala Harris his dad is also
ripping into Hearst that's kind of
hilarious
apparently he's very angry at her
because in a recent interview she
suggested she'd smoke pot because half
of her family was from Jamaica and her
dad called his daughters remarks a
travesty and accused her of stereotyping
he said my dear departed grandmother as
well as my deceased parents must be
turning in their grave right now to see
their family's name reputation and proud
Jamaican identity being connected in any
way jokingly or not with the fraudulent
stereotype of a pot smoking joy seeker
and in the pursuit of
identity politics Harris is an economics
professor at Stanford University and
this is recorded report about the
Washington Times and speaking for myself
in my immediate Jamaican family we wish
to categorically disassociate ourselves
from this travesty boom now getting
smacked our campaign is getting smacked
by her own dad now what you think that
might be like a little bit of news of
sure Republican she's a Democrat so
nobody's ever heard that story nor will
they okay time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like
it's an unusual day I'm about to tell
you about a thing that I like that comes
courtesy of Barack Obama now one of the
tragedies of Barack Obama's presidency
in my view it truly is a tragedy Barack
Obama could have been a transformational
president he really could have when he
was elected he was elected with an
overwhelming majority he had approval
ratings in the high 80s when he took
office and he immediately went into
intersectional mode he immediately
started doubling down on the idea that
all attacks on him were attacks on his
race he immediately started pushing the
notion that far left is impose the way
to unify the United States but Barack
Obama was not elected for that he was
elected to unify imagine if Barack Obama
had called for a conciliatory America
imagine if Obama had come into office
and the first time there was a racial
incident like say Henry Louis Gates
you'll recall that skip gates professor
at Harvard went to his house tried to
break into his own house because he'd
never skis a neighbor saw him breaking
into his house didn't know he was a
neighbor called the cops the cops showed
up
gates refused to show ID it became a
national incident and Obama said that
the Cambridge police had acted stupidly
and then we had to have a beer summit he
basically called them racist he talked
about racist policing imagine if he had
said listen misunderstandings happen in
the United States on a regular basis
that doesn't make Henry Lewis gates
wrong to suspect that bad things have
happened in the past but it also doesn't
make him right and it doesn't mean that
the Cambridge police are racist maybe if
we saw each other with a little more
grace the country would be a better
place imagine if you had done that
imagine if there had been a situation
where a Republican was caught let's say
with a Ralph Northern type situation
thirty years ago that person had a
picture in their yearbook that was
racist and Obama as a black president
had said listen we ought to show people
grace people change over time and
America has changed over time which is
why I'm president imagine the amount of
the world of good that
have done for the United States instead
Obama didn't do that but here's the
saddest part Obama had the capacity to
do that
and now that he's not president
sometimes he actually says intelligent
things like this right you'll recall
that during the 2016 race he actually
made some speeches in which he talked
about why campuses should be open places
for inquiry
and he shouldn't have speeches trying to
be shut down that was really good well
he gave a speech yesterday in Oakland
California in which he talked about
masculinity he said all of us have to
recognize that being a man is first and
foremost being a good human that means
being responsible working hard being
kind respectful and compassionate the
notion that somehow defining herself as
a man is dependent on are you able to
put someone else down able to dominate
that is an old view and then he says if
you're confident about your strengths
you don't need to show me by putting
somebody else down and show me by
lifting somebody else up and then he got
into some really good stuff he really
did he talked he was talking for an
initiative called my brother's keeper
initiative he talked about how racism
historically sends a message that you
are less than and we feel we have to
compensate by exaggerating stereotypical
ways men are supposed to act and that's
a trap there are some truth to that
there is some truth to that that racism
historically has said to black men that
you are you are less than and so what
that leads to is a chip on the shoulder
and a feeling like you have to act out
aggressively to prove your masculinity
that's not completely false what Obama
is saying here but the best thing that
he said is he started talking about how
it's a self-defeating model for being a
man to act in these ways he talked about
how hip-hop and rap are often built
around talking about how I have more
money than you
I can disrespect you he said ironically
that shows the vulnerability you feel if
your confidence about your sexuality you
don't have to have eight women around
you twerking you seem stressed that you
got to be acting that way I got one
woman who I'm very happy with he added
where was this guy like every so often
he showed up during his presidency and
says stuff like this but it was
dominated by campaigning it was
dominated by hardcore politics if this
had been the leading edge of his
presidency you know how much better the
country would have been you know much
better the country would have been I
mean really this could have been such it
could've been such a great thing and
it's a tragedy for the country that
Obama didn't do this more while he was
president I'm glad that he is doing it
now so praise to Barack Obama for saying
some true things about masculinity being
a man is about being a responsible man
taking care of your wife taking care of
your children taking care of your
neighbors building your community
that's what being responsible Anusol
about if Barack Obama and I can agree on
that hopefully you know that'll be a
starting point for the revision of
masculinity in the country more
generally by the way and the one thing I
don't like about this is the idea that
toxic masculinity is so prevalent the
truth is traditional masculinity was all
the things that I'm talking about
traditional masculinity was about taking
care of your family being responsible
building your community okay time for
some things that I hate Martina
Navratilova probably the greatest
women's player of all time outside of
Serena Williams and tennis she has now
been removed as an ambassador by athlete
Ally an organization that supports LGBT
athletes why Martina Navratilova one of
the first open lesbians in major sport
they took a lot of risks to be that why
is she being ousted she's being ousted
because she referred to trans women as
men who decides to be female in a
newspaper column this week which is true
adding that allowing them to compete
with women who were assigned female at
birth is cheating and unfair which of
course is exactly true her comments were
heavily criticized and described as
disturbing upsetting and deeply
transphobic by the rights group
transaction and now athlete ally aus a
nonprofit organization that campaigns
for greater inclusion in sport in a
statement the organization said athlete
ally unequivocally stands on the side of
trans a feats and the right to access
and compete in sport free from
discrimination Martina Navratilova
recent comments on trans athletes are
transphobic based on a false
understanding of science and data and
perpetuate dangerous myths that leads to
the ongoing targeting of trans people no
this is not mythical it is not mythical
to suggest that genetic men have a
sports advantage over genetic women of
course this is true of course this is
stress too tested yesterday went the
fastest women in the world they're there
two thousand for every fast woman in the
world like at the upper ranks there
2,000 men faster there is a study that
was recently done and said the average
woman that the fastest woman throwing a
baseball like the woman who throws
fastest or the the who throws a baseball
the fastest in the United States
the vast majority of men can throw a
baseball faster than that and the fact
is men have more upper body strength
it's just evolutionary biology there is
nothing new about this this is basic
basic science there's a reason that
Renee Richards who you'll recall
as one of the first openly trans people
in the United States was a former
ophthalmologist who was like an amateur
tennis player was an amateur tennis
player and he is his name was Richard
Raskind a nice Jewish boy she he then
had a sex change and was just like a
mildly competitive tennis player was
ranked 6th out of 20 males over the over
out of the top 20 males over 35 in in
the United States and then began
dressing his woman had a sex change
and suddenly was one of the top tennis
players in the world as a woman
Richard's played professionally from
1977 to 1981 when he retired at age 47
he was ranked as high as 20th overall he
was legitimately like just a mediocre
men's tennis player and suddenly who's
ranked 20th overall as like a 40 year
old that's because men are stronger than
women on average Martina Navratilova is
of course exactly correct about this
Martina Navratilova one of the great
pioneers in the LGBT movement has
decided it has been ousted from her own
movement now it really is astonishing
other articles along these lines this
one is pretty spectacular I kind of love
this one this is by Mathew Gault from
Vice calm facial recognition software
regularly miss genders trans people
right correct because you know what
facial recognition software does it
identifies what you look like and most
trans people look like their genetic
selves and what are they supposed to
identify your soul your brain like it's
called facial recognition it's not
called self assigned gender recognition
this human computer interfaces are
almost never built with transgender
people in mind and continue to reinforce
existing biases what in the actual hell
so what is technology designed to
identify I'm so confused by this this is
like saying you know what regularly most
genders people genetic testing genetic
testing regularly miss genders people
like when you do a genetic test and it
turns out that you have zero Y
chromosomes and so we label you a female
that is science misgendering you man
trans movement really undermines their
own credibility when they get into this
stuff if they want to make the case the
only logically consistent case for trans
rights is that gender is entirely
separate from biology now that is not
true there's no evidence to support that
but the idea that gender is completely
separate from biology and therefore can
be arbitrarily applied and self applied
but that biology is biology so in other
words a trans male is still a biological
woman but identifies his female that at
least has some internal logic to it but
if you are claiming now that trans women
are genetic women or biological women or
that facial recognition software using
objective metrics are supposed to
identify you as the gender to which you
claim identity what in the world are you
even talking about this leads to some
rather weird places there is a a person
I've never heard of this person
apparently there's a show called pose
and there's an actress named India Moore
and this trans star who I guess is a
genetic male wrote on February 17th
quote if a woman has a penis her penis
is a biologically female penis no okay
so let me explain some basic science the
entire history of humanity the
progenitor the the creation of new human
beings is reliant on the sexual
dichotomy between male and female this
is true in all mammalian species by the
way not just for for humans you know we
never asked what orangutan self identify
as because we know because then they
have sex with each other and have new
baby orangutans there's no such thing as
a female penis that is absurd it's not a
biologically female what what are we
insane and then the good news is that
it's a self refuting assessment so this
person writes if a woman has a penis
her penis is a biologically female penis
a biologically female penis does not
exist therefore a woman does not have a
penis just if we're going to complete
the syllogism this is how nonsensical
we've become honestly if you want to
make a case for trans rights you cannot
overwrite biology and pretend it doesn't
exist
it just it undermines your entire cause
totally insane all righty so we will be
back here a little bit later today with
two more hours of Content ID so much I
wanted to get to today that I didn't
have a chance to get to this is why you
ought to subscribe over at daily we're
calm go do that for 99 bucks a year you
will enjoy it
I promise or show up tomorrow and we'll
be be here with you again to get update
you on the news I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wired production
copyright daily wire 20 19